Human beings are
natural storytellers.
The purpose of storytelling
is to connect us together.
I storytell as an actor,
a director, as a writer,
as a producer, as
a public speaker.
Storytelling is one of
the primary building
blocks of civilization.
Everything that is
important to us as a species
has been contained in stories.
In this MasterClass,
I'm going to help
you identify your personal
story; at home, at work, in play,
helping make you a more
effective communicator.
I'm going to touch
on storytelling
for children, storytelling for
adults, and public speaking.
I'm nervous every time
I speak in public.
I'm going to say that again.
I've been doing
this for 45 years.
Every time I open my mouth
in public, I'm nervous.
There is a phrase
that I love using.
Fear is simply
suppressed excitement.
We all have nervousness.
And suppressed excitement
is a lot easier
to deal with intellectually
than our fear.
"This storm will pass
soon," said Papa.
"Would you like me
to read you a story?
I know just the one to
help you feel better."
When I was a kid,
you were either going
to read a book in
my mother's home,
or you were going
to get hit with one.
It was your choice.
But you were going to have an
experience with the written
word.
I come from a family of
teachers, of educators.
So it's my turn.
Storytelling is a gateway
to our imagination.
We can't have a just,
equitable society
unless we can imagine one.
We are here to contribute
something mighty.
And our storytelling is
the ship that we sail on.
I'm LeVar Burton, and this
is my MasterClass.